hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the thing
tonight I don't know why but I'm always
compulsive that servants room to keep I
was assuming that something was gonna
spawn because every time I picked up a
key before something has spawned ah I'm
gonna be very sparing about not I was
wrong
that's what's so wrong oh that's Sarah's
room Sarah man I need some healing
actually yeah no stopping creepy I heard
okay
now maybe I said other door in the other
whoa oh I forgot about them cool who's
just the shadows of them oh oh
close that door knows it knows it keep
it close
oh God Oh nope not that one either
well there's a pickle maybe I missed a
door this one yeah maybe this one I
think Oh
oh I knew it was gonna be bad Oh oh this
ain't good good Jim oh good nothing what
was that
[Music]
you kidding me they're gonna be joking
me oh I've never tried more desperately
to getting into a closet I've been
hearing faint screams at night but it
may be the castle doing some weird
noises because it's really old
still the Masters son has told me that
some prisoners have gone missing
I'm not down there much time to know
about that but if he's right I don't
have to watch out for them my best mates
gone missing when I asked master what
happened to him he just said that he let
him go all those Begala belongings are
still here so I know something is going
on now I'll begin to lock my door at
night I made a key to the lab from where
the screams have been coming it's time
to find out what's happening happening
in reality I'll hide the key in the
cellar when I'm working tomorrow if I
don't write another letter something
must have happened to me something
happen to him yeah you cannot for me
damn okay
anything else oh what's this something
in need of punishment
[Music]
okay ah
Tara serve not even realize it started
by an illusion unless there's gonna give
you that hug that I've missed since
penumbra Black Plague kliklak
[Music]
I was like really creepy do you hear
that so we're like distorted woman's
screaming in the background I don't
think I've ever heard that before
either I haven't or I haven't been
paying attention enough for the seller
my brother is dead I don't know if mom
my mom is alright
father you will pay for all the lives
you've stolen traitor boldly stated but
there is nothing that you can did you
think we had forgotten did you think we
had forgiven now is the our way no
that's a it's been a while since I
watched our Delano any of you know what
I was talking about if you did you
played the same game I did way too much
candles oh it's super dark everywhere I
go
I was behold now our terrible vengeance
Sylvanas - I better not just stand
around I'm gonna waste oil okay
something is going on down here the
water flights in the lower cellar were
broken and something is growing down
there I'll make two chemicals that if
you mix together it will make a powerful
acid to melt the web-like slime growing
in the lower cellar but there isn't much
to use there is much so use it wisely
the firing rods have gone missing I put
one at my desk here in the cellar but
two have gone missing somewhere here in
the cellar and I need them so I can get
the gate up and pick up my lab key for
now wait bread good boys oh yeah oh oh
three parts back down there
Hojo test it out for me barrel thank you
[Music]
okay that's not good
ah what's down there ground amazing
better double-check yep
it's dirt hmm what does this mean I
don't know I'll figure it out on my own
I don't like this place I'm gonna say
that straight up I don't like I mean
there's not many places in amnesia
custom stories that I do like you know
pleasantly say nice and dandy but yeah I
don't
[Music]
okay that whispering is new quickly I
got plenty of sanity and health posters
behind usually end up I usually end up
didn't oh where oh where is it where is
it hiding the clue hidey-hidey-ho oh
[Music]
where is he oh oh no you st. good okay
I think that might have just been faking
faking it was because if there was an
actual monster it probably do the
monster music that's usually a pretty
old man this guy got smashed Wow how did
that guy die oh oh oh what's coming out
is what the new machine room huh I like
those old machines although you don't
know what they're doing it the world it
softener machines ever gonna run the
world someday they need to just get out
of the way Kapow nice pirouette hammer
very manly
ah just oh thank you thank you so much
oh thank you thank you
Oh ad thank you it's not as good an
offering as the other ones but thank you
nonetheless okay maybe I can climb up
man I would have hated to live in this
town oh okay I gotcha
it looks like the firing rods are
missing I will need to find him okay
cool
got a new machine like how did this one
board double kill these guys think you
think one boy would have been like and
then the other guys like yeah they
crapped his pants fine here there's
something something back here what's
back bones lots of bones looks like
these guys whatever sunglasses got boom
like my sunglasses you know side glasses
don't judge me
same difference all right
ah the whispering needs to stop I go up
here
Oh what secret Easter egg yes please
secret Easter egg yes please come great
I'm the best I bet that was a toad
secret oh I think that was at all oh
yeah
seems it was hidden a long time ago oh I
get unless a part of this story knows
I'm gonna act like I wasn't supposed to
find that job
I need the firing last Endora seems
logical
cuz that's one iced tea door okay these
barrels a place so that I can hide
behind
[Music]
I should have known that it was gonna be
a disappear
okay all right whatever getting over
that oh god okay I got this key all
right okay whatever I'm fine I'm fine
the door open in my face hi hello yeah
okay you want a barrel it's not what
you're saying there you go barrels I
will drown you in barrels Wow
sorry about the water Oh
Oh accidentally burst a barrel oh I got
to keep my powers in check when that
happen what oh this is the coolest thing
ever
yeah whoa how is this happening
I don't care but it is awesome oh it's
like a what how is that even possible
I don't even know but I'm wishing oil oh
it sucked it right in
put some barrel vacuum good golly maybe
I could stack up and get over
nope I can't cause it's just gonna suck
them through
just like your mama maybe I can maybe I
get difficult don't go through the wall
please I'm trying to get somewhere here
Fang up there and I should just need
like three down y'all right y'all yeah
okay up said huh hip hop hip and popping
in it's not happening I'm not hopping in
there we go I don't see that monster
button up invisible wall hey it'd be
like that fine
I guess that was a fruitless endeavor
[Music]
whatever don't matter to me I'm okay
with that
doc God whispering needs to stop
I swear
okay this is the other side anyway damn
raccoons okay anyway I'm out of time so
it's gonna have to wait until next part
so thank you all so much for watching
and as always see you in the next video
bye bye